With us now, former Illinois
Republican Congressman Joe Walsh hosts
the White Flag
Politics podcast
and also seen Inside
Politics Sunday, anchor Abby Phillip.
Abby,
so Santos is saying he wants to properly
clear his name
before returning to his committees,
as we see on a daily basis,
including this last sort of interview.
He's not forthcoming
with regard to the vast
majority of his lies.
I mean,
does this just kind of
slug along and careen along like this?
I think it's going to, Anderson.
I mean, look, the by
this latest
move really just shows
that Republican leadership is not willing
to put public pressure on George Santos
to step aside or really to do anything.
They allowed this move or of him
recusing himself
from the committee
to be his
to be framed
at least publicly as his decision.
Even though it's clear here
that it's it's
something that actually benefits
Kevin McCarthy
as he's trying to go
about the rest of the agenda
that he's laid out for his party.
This is not someone in George
Santos who has a lot of remorse
or even a lot of shame
for some of the lies that he's told you.
You played so many of them today.
But, you know, he hasn't even explained.
Reporters were asking him questions
about why he claimed his mother
died on nine 11
when she wasn't even in the country.
I mean, these are
some of these
lies are really reprehensible.
And this is not someone
who seems to be
having any sort of real remorse over
his willingness
to lie to his constituents
and the country in this way.
Yeah.
I mean, Congressman Walsh,
do you actually believe
this is Santos
voluntarily stepping down
from his committees?
And that guy who seems so shameless,
he just met recently
privately with Kevin McCarthy.
Do you think it's very possible
that McCarthy,
you know, suggested or told him, look,
take attention away from us
and away from yourself,
step down from these committees and
let this thing work out?
Oh, absolutely, Anderson.
I think it's probable
that McCarthy told them,
hey, look, buddy, help me out here.
Right. I want.
Here's the deal.
Kevin McCarthy needs to be speaker.
He needs to stay speaker.
He needs this Santo stuff
to kind of try to go quiet.
And the other thing, Anderson,
is Kevin McCarthy,
because his caucus is demanding it is
hell bent on removing Ilhan Omar
from her committee,
which is a despicable thing to do.
But this puts McCarthy
in a real tough spot
if he's still got George
Santos on all these committees.
Anderson, I got to say,
the Santos is a huge distraction
to Republicans
But, man,
Republicans created this distraction
because from the moment this news broke,
as you demonstrated,
they've never held them accountable.
And here's the damnedest thing, Anderson.
It's only going to get worse.
We're talking about his lies now.
We're going to be talking
about federal crimes in federal finance,
campaign finance violations pretty soon.
Abby, you heard Congressman Santos
in that softball interview
say that
that he's learned his lesson
and from now on,
everything is going to be above board.
Is there a possible move
that voters in his district
would try to recall him?
Is there anything chance of that?
Well, look, I think that from everything
that we've seen,
has a lot of voters in his district
are trying to put as much pressure
as they can
to force him into a resignation.
I just don't think that there's
much from him,
from the mechanics
of how these elections work for them.
To do that.
There's no sort of,
you know,
recall procedure
like there is in some other states.
So they're really in a bind here
and they're relying on
just using their voices
and the bully pulpit
that they have as voters.
I think a lot of his voters right now
feel pretty powerless in this situation,
and so do his colleagues in New York.
Are the Republicans in that state
are trying to get this guy out
as quickly as possible
because they believe
that it reflects negatively on them.
These are Republicans,
many of them in purple states
that Biden won.
They believe they're the tip of the spear
when it comes to a Republican majority.
And they're worried about what
this could all mean for them.
In two years
when they are
up for reelection once again.
And they have to answer for why
George Santos's
lies wasn't enough for him
to be
really pushed to the corners of the party
or pushed out of the party
in this Congress.
Congressman Walsh, does this hurt
the people in his district?
I mean,
if he's completely just,
you know, constantly
scuttling about,
you know, trying to avoid things
and not on any committees?
And does he get to.
Does he actually do anything?
Does he actually serve his constituents?
No, Anderson.
And that's such a great point.
That's the pathetic
deal here is that district for two years
will in essence,
go without a representative.
And shame on George Santos for that.
But really, Anderson,
shame on
the entire Republican conference.
Abby's right
that members of the New York delegation
have spoken out against him.
But doggone it,
he's lied about everything.
The entire conference
should call him out.
McCarthy should call him out.
But they won't.
I don't think
he's running again, Anderson.
I think they've probably already
cut that deal.
And he'll just try his best
to be quiet for two years.
Joe Walsh, Abby Phillip, thanks.
I appreciate it.